foreign
for some reason Dave yet again he locks
are all the rage and it's it's not
enough that you can you know pull the
equity on your home now they've turned
it into a whole thing this is called the
Avon credit card but it's not like all
the other credit cards Dave because
those other credit cards they're bad bad
bad they're unsecured debt wouldn't it
be nice to have one that's secured debt
yeah so when you buy a steak you can't
afford
at the restaurant
you lose your home oh there you go
because you pledged to Collateral a
steak
nice trade and that's what they're
saying they're saying what wouldn't it
be nice to have a credit card that lets
you use your home equity to get really
low rates it lets you this is a
privilege Dave that we so sweet of them
they're so service minded and I love
that it says you get really really low
rates between
7.99 and 14.99 variable interest
better than a credit card is it
you know one of these credit card rating
service people called and wanted me to
comment on a thing the other day and our
PR team went um
did you get a wrong number
because Dave's credit card has a zero
interest he doesn't have a credit card
that's the rate on mine zero interest
debit card
that's all I use
I haven't had a credit card since 1988.
because to start with we filed
bankruptcy they wouldn't give us one
and then later but we also made the
decision we weren't borrowing money ever
again for any reason and we walked
around in a non-debit card Society for a
little while with no credit cards and
that was tough I bet it was yeah I flew
to New York and couldn't check into a
hotel it was ridiculous wow I mean I I
no matter how much cash I flashed they
wouldn't let me in it was crazy so wow
yeah it was a problem now you got debit
cards does everything credit card does
so uh and except charge you 7.9 interest
on your home equity loan what do you
lost your mind people
but you don't think Dave that it's worth
it to leverage your home for 1.5
unlimited cash back Unlimited
Unlimited
so let me get this straight
I pay out
a hundred dollars
and I get back
a dollar fifty yes
you know what I'm gonna get rich trading
a hundred for a dollar fifty and that's
what needs to be called out that's I
that's that's there's so much wisdom in
that I mean everyone knows when you
trade a hundred for a dollar fifty
you're going to Bill wealth quickly yeah
it's the idios it's unlimited unlimited
cash stupidity is unlimited
here here's the worst part
um you only need as much as five
thousand dollars equity in your home
and they're willing to give you that on
a line of credit on the Haven credit
card they're just amazingly they're just
Equity kindest crocodiles the whole the
whole point in buying the home part of
it was to build wealth
pulling the wealth out
y'all didn't see the commercial for this
in the commercial they're swiping the
Avon card for books
in a jewelry store in a clothing store
that's what they're using their home
equity on that's what people are using
this money for yours your you're trading
your freedom and your wealth
for
shirts
6.50 back
out of every hundred
I don't want to hear anybody complaining
about the state of their finances if
anybody is willing to get on board with
if you're willing to get on the board
with things like this don't come
complaining and don't come crying to me
this is terrible and you heard it first
here these are bad bad bad ideas Dave
they're bad
what you I can't even say it's marketing
the marketing is so pleasant it seems so
reasonable it calls it a credit card up
front home equity in the back
some like it's a mullet it's a money
mullet
[Laughter]
all business up front a party in the
back yes
with 14.99 added pain and regret that's
all Financial mullet
[Laughter]
it has a new name it's called Avon yes
the financial mullet for you yes
Financial mullet buck and a half it's
gonna cost you you'll get that back for
every 100 you spend you get a dollar and
a half back you go and get your mullet
and
they're going to give you spend 100
bucks you're gonna give you a buck and a
half back in a mullet oh gosh I love it
that's it that's exactly the line it's
exactly the line a credit card up front
a home equity loan in the back
just all businesses up front and a party
in the back oh oh God I cannot make this
crap up